looks like
looks like we got competition I'll fix
this but I'm gonna need some help let's
catch some Multiverse men just run it by
us next time you break the universe deal
Spider-Man
you're not Peter Parker I am so confused
right now that's about the Jukebox
started pulling in visitors from every
universe
the Multiverse is real
they all die finding Spider-Man there
has to be another way there isn't there
are danger to our universe
is all my fault I can't save everyone
Spider-Man no way home in theaters
December 17th what's happening they're
starting to come through and I can't
stop them well you're thinking I'm about
to do something that could break the
Universe I know you run it by us we need
to send them back
[Music]
you're flying out into the darkness to
fight ghosts what do you mean they all
die fighting Spider-Man I'm sorry kid
yeah me too don't
there has to be another way there is it
Spiderman no way home I underestimated
you Peter do I know you
looks like we got competition
we started getting some visitors in
their Universe they all die finding
Spider-Man
I'm sorry kid yeah me too
there has to be another way person
what's happening they're starting to
come through I can't stop them Spiderman
no way home ever since I got bit by that
spider
we had one week where my life has felt
normal that was when you found out
Peter
spell that you buy started pulling into
every Universe what's happening they're
starting to come through and I can't
stop him Spider-Man no way home in
theaters December 17th
hello Peter do I know you you think your
fancy new suit's Gonna Save You
looks like we got competition